♪♪
>> THE SHOT IS BLOCKED.
>> HOLIDAY RIPS IT AWAY.
>> AND SLAM IT!
HOW ABOUT THAT.
>> THE MILWAUKEE BUCKS ARE NBA
CHAMPIONS ONCE AGAIN.
>> AND NOW FOR THE PRESENTATION
OF CHAMPIONSHIP RINGS TO YOUR
2021 NBA WORLD CHAMPION
MILWAUKEE BUCKS AND FORWARD FROM
FRANCE, NUMBER 66, AXEL TOUPANE.
AT FORWARD FROM LOUISVILLE,
NUMBER 13, JORDAN NWORA.
AT GUARD FROM VILLANOVA, 00,
DONTE DIVINCENZO.
AT FORWARD, FROM GREECE, 43,
THANASIS ANTETOKOUNMPO.
AT FORWARD FROM NOTRE DAME, 44,
PAT CONNAUGHTNON.
AT FORWARD FROM ARKANSAS, 9,
BOBBY PORTIS.
AT CENTER, FROM STANFORD, 11,
BROOK LOPEZ.
AT GUARD FROM UCLA, 21, JRUE
HOLIDAY.
AT FORWARD FROM TEXAS A&M, KHRIS
MIDDLETON.
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, AT
FORWARD FROM GREECE, FINALS MVP,
NUMBER 34, GIANNIS
ANTETOKOUNMPO!
AND NOW, IT IS TIME TO UNVEIL
THE CHAMPIONSHIP BANNER, BUT